[Music]
i'm nadia drake with national geographic
today we're at nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory with chris evans who plays
buzz lightyear in the new disney and
pixar movie lightyear hanging out with
the intrepid freshly returned from orbit
astronaut tom marshburn i have been
completely fascinated with space travel
all things nasa since i was a kid so the
fact that my new film light year has let
me speak to actual astronauts is a real
dream come true let's find out what life
in space is really like here we go
and of course tom has actually been to
space what's it like to look up into
space you really fall in love with the
earth again every continent has its
incredibly beautiful sights do the stars
look different the stars look gorgeous
but they don't twinkle because there's
no atmosphere during the day it's just
black
and that is to me the most riveting
thing
i can see stars that is space what is
happening right now she's afraid of
space what she should be it's horrible
what was harder than you expected about
being in orbit it's really hard to move
around with control it's hard to stop
that somebody's got to grab you and
plant you somewhere and get your feet
somewhere it amazes me we can get
science done up there with everything
floating around all the time in our film
uh lightyear buzz has a robot companion
socks this little cat hello buzz i am
socks your personal companion robot how
do you cope with being so alone we got
each other but we also have all the
mission controls and there are some
floating ai robots up there like taking
pictures where we need them put a light
where we need it so i've heard that some
astronauts get space sickness please
record your last words do not vomit
inside the
vehicle about three out of five get some
form of nausea there's no up down left
or right so your body feels like it's
spinning getting used to that is kind of
tough and also your stomach's floating
everything on the inside is floating
jpl this is mission control houston
this is tom chris and nadia we hear you
loud and clear tom great to hear your
voice just seems like yesterday that
you're up here with us so so i can only
imagine what's some of the hardest parts
of training we trained in a giant pool
called the neutral buoyancy laboratory
it enables us to understand how to move
outside years of training goes into
preparing for the actual flight itself
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something in our film buzz
has to utilize light speed to accomplish
his missions how fast were you guys
moving on the journey up there and how
fast you guys moving now on iss you know
we essentially start at a relative speed
of zero on the ground and then with
eight and a half minutes we're traveling
17 500 miles per hour and that's what
we're doing right now five miles per
second and the other incredible thing is
that when it's time to come home we've
got to shed that speed to get home
safely i'm curious about the food on
board how many michelin stars would you
give the chefs our space food lab does
an amazing job so half of that food is
rehydrated we add water to it and then
the other half is prepared and then
sealed in these kind of metallic
envelopes and then we put those on
essentially a hot plate
i really miss you guys y'all stay safe
can't wait to see you this was fantastic
easily the best part of press i've ever
done and probably one of my favorite
conversations of my life roger that
thanks for joining us here at jpl and i
hope you enjoyed hanging out with tom
and chris and our friends aboard the
international space station disney and
pixar's light year great pg now playing
only in peters